Hi ihr Lieben!
Heute habe ich mir überlegt: Es ist so schönes Wetter
und ich will gar nicht soo lange in der Küche stehen,
möchte aber trotzdem was leckeres essen, was ich mir gleich auf dem Balkon gönne!
Deshalb gibt's heute Apfelkuchen aus nur 6 Zutaten der in 10min backofenbereit ist!
Und ich hab jetzt hier die Küchenmaschine und da sind schon Eier drin.
Da gebe ich jetzt auch noch Zucker rein und Va-
oh jetzt wollte ich schon fast das Mehl reingeben! -
Zucker rein und das Vanilleextrakt.
Und dann schlagen wir das Ganze gleich ungefähr 8min lang auf höchster Stufe,
dann wird's richtig schön dick-cremig!
(H: Die Mengenangaben findet ihr...?)
In der Videobeschreibung!
Wir sind ein richtiges Dream Team heute!
So, ich stelle das hier auf 8min ein.
Wenn ihr ein Handrührgerät nehmt, dann braucht ihr so ungefähr 10-11min.
So...6,7,8, okay! Das lasse ich jetzt wie gesagt mixen
und in der Zwischenzeit hier die Äpfel, die werde ich dann schälen und in kleine Häppchen schneiden.
So, die Äpfel sind vorbereitet, die Eiermasse ist richtig schön hell-cremig
und jetzt kommen zum Einsatz Mehl und Backpulver.
Das siebe ich einfach - ach das siebe ich! -
das verrühre ich einmal kurz vorab und dann siebe ich es in die Masse.
Auch nur ganz kurz, es darf sich nur ganz kurz miteinander verbinden!
Und dann kommen schon die Äpfel mit dazu, aber nicht alle.
Ein paar hebe ich mir noch auf, die gebe ich dann nämlich oben drauf.
So, den Teig füllen wir jetzt in eine 24cm Springform
die vorab mit Backpapier ausgelegt wurde.
Und die restlichen Äpfel jetzt ganz einfach an der Oberfläche verteilen
und anschließend wird der Apfelkuchen im vorgeheizten Backofen gebacken bis er goldbraun ist.
Wichtig ist, dass ihr eben den Ofen auf 180° C Ober- und Unterhitze vorheizt.
Und wir sehen uns nach dem Backen wieder!
So, nach dem Backen könnt ihr den Apfelkuchen lauwarm genießen
oder ihr könnt's abkühlen lassen, ein bisschen Puderzucker drauf und fertig!
Und ihr habt ja jetzt gesehen, das ist in der 24er Springform relativ hoch geworden.
Benutzt gerne auch eine 26er Springform, das ist komplett euch überlassen!
Die Backzeit variiert da nur minimal um ein paar Minuten.
Macht generell immer gern die Stäbchenprobe und dann seid ihr immer safe!
Ansonsten wünsche ich euch jetzt ganz viel Freude beim Nachbacken,
lasst gerne einen Daumen nach oben da, darüber würde ich mich sehr sehr freuen!
Ansonsten abonniert doch kostenlos meinen Kanal,
dann seid ihr immer up to date und verpasst nix!
(H: Die freut sich echt über einen Daumen nach oben, ne?)
Ja, ich freu mich wirklich!
Ich zähl' dann immer abends: "Ah, heute waren es so viele!"
Nein, also so schlimm ist es nicht, aber ich freue mich wirklich sehr.
Und dann sehen wir uns beim nächsten Rezept!
Also Tschüss, eure Kiki und der Hamza hinter der Kamera!
(H: Tschüüss!)